We've seen how expensive it would be to track all the photons in a scene. To
avoid this level of computation. In computer graphics, we make a number of
simplifying assumptions. First, only those photons that reach the camera are the
ones needed to make the image. So, these are the only ones we would like to
compute. We know which objects we can see. But how do we know in advance which
photons will matter? Each photon is generated by a light source, but we don't
know where each ends up. So, we reverse the process. Instead of sending photons
from the light, we essentially cast a ray from the eye through each pixel and
see what's out there. When a surface is seen at a pixel, we then compute the
direct effect of each light on that surface. Add up all the light contributions
and you have a reasonable proximation of what the surface looks like. One more
approximation can be used for these lights, nothing blocks them every surface is
considered visible to a light unless it faces away from that light source, in
other words no objects casts shadows. This simplification saves us a lot of
computation. Rendering can get even simpler than this. For example, you could do
away with lights all together and just draw each object with a solid color.
However, I'm drawing the line there as lights add considerable realism and
perception of 3D to a scene. For example, look at this scene with, without
lights. So there are two extremes. At one end photons are carefully traced from
light emitters through a scene, potentially giving a highly realistic image. At
the other end the camera determines what gets viewed and a rough approximation
of what light reaches each surface is determined. This process can be
unrealistic but can be computed extremely fast, We'll start with a second
extreme and, and in later lessons show how we can remove or modify various
simplifications, so the more photon based computations are performed, such as
casting shadows.